you ever get into Super normal stimuli
what's that how like they trick
butterflies into dedicating their whole
lives yeah this is all I've ever wanted
for seven years
they wondering how he would do I knew
you're gonna do this he sent me the
longest [__] time like bummed out
that he's asking me to have you come
along and I was like yeah for sure
it was like eight texts that's what kind
of guy he is dude it is risky because
you don't know he'd be like this
[__]
he knows me I know we're friends but
like it's still like a hey you want me
to bring another guy it's kind of no
yeah I know let's go but I also knew I
knew in my heart of hearts Matt would
rise to the occasion and say things like
have you ever heard of super stimuliar
dude no it's a rich I knew it was it
it's [__] up to think about because so
they